hello everyone uh i'm chen liu zhang
from microsoft research asia
in this talk scarlett and i will
introduce richard
a deep learning exploratory training
framework
online this system is designed for
efficient
dna model exploration
this is the agenda of our talk first i
will introduce richard
as the research work then my colleague
scarlett will introduce how richard
is implemented online and how to use
richard
online as we all know
deep neural networks have become
prevalent
dna models are being adopted in both
cloud and edge
more and more scenarios and applications
are powered
by dn techniques so it's important to
design
a good deal model for each given task
designing a deep learning model is very
different
from traditional big data tasks
for a big data task for example word
count
developers write a script after script
is executed on targeted data we get the
result
the task is done however a deep learning
task
is not training a given model
instead its goal is to find a good model
for a specific task
for example designing a dna model
for detecting faces on an edge device
it has both accuracy and latency
constraints
designing a deep learning model is
mainly an exploratory
process it usually starts with the hunch
for example from some well-known good
performing neural architectures
as a basis to produce a concrete model
then training this model to check how it
performs
based on the training performance the
developer manually or automatically
refines the model
for getting better performance after
checking its training results
the developer modifies the model again
and transit
this process is repeated until the
desired model
is found we call this process
exploratory training let's look at some
typical modifications
to models during exploratory training
the graphs represent dna models when
designing a model
developers do some of these
modifications to find
better models first developers may
replace
an operator with another one for example
changing activation operation from relu
to leaky value
i'll try to add skip connections
also there could be some rule-based
model modifications
like replacing some specific layers with
another one
or inserting operators after specific
layers
another modification type is
generalizing a block structure
here is an example exception block is
shown on the left
it has the four passes with one operator
on each path
it's intuitive to try different model
structures
while keeping its mind skeleton for
example
changing the number of passes and
changing
the operator on each path
the last one is that a model
architecture could gradually grow
following some rules for example we can
grow a model
by adding layers to adapt the model to
harder tasks
similarly we can gradually shrink large
model
to adapt to easier tasks all these model
architecture modifications
are very common during designing a new
model
however existing frameworks have very
weak support to
exploratory training because they only
focus
on a single dna model however
programming and
training one dna model is just one step
of the exploratory training process
although
they are tools for neural active search
or hyper parameter optimization
many of them lack modularity and
programmability
making oneness or hpo solution only
applicable to one kind of neural
architecture
or only works for a specific task
on the other hand the models explored
during exploratory training could have
high similarity among each other there
are great opportunities
to leverage such similarity to speed up
exploratory training process which are
mixed by existing frameworks and
tools way of
programming dn has been evolved from
programming with native c plus plus r
matlab to deep learning frameworks like
uh python
tensorflow given that we have understood
the exploratory training
uh process of designing deep learning
models
we believe this is a good time to
rethink dna framework
what should we do to make the end-to-end
experience of
developing our dna model much easier and
faster
here comes our system richard richard is
designed as a
deep learning framework for exploratory
training
rather than a single dna model it could
make
model exploration more systematic and
programmable exploration strategies and
auxins become modular and fully reusable
by various exploratory training tasks
moreover it enables cross-model
optimizations
to greatly speed up the exploratory
training process
we position richard as a to dm framework
to greatly help developers design new
dna models
take the previous examples we can see
that
exploratory training is a series of
model mutations
the possible mutations build a model
space
explore exploratory training explores
the models in this space
to find the best one
we design mutator as the core
abstraction
mutator decouples model space from
exploration strategy mutator could
express
arbitrary model space making it easy for
developers to
express a bunch of possible models they
want to try
exploration strategy can understand and
search
the model spaces that i expressed with
mutators
meanwhile mutator natively tracks the
relations between models thus it exposes
many cross-model optimization
opportunities
richard provides a new mutator based
programming paradigm
for users to program a model space
rather than
a single model due to their decouple of
model space and
exploration strategy they become
highly composable a model space can try
different
exploration strategies at last
the cross model optimization techniques
in richard
greatly speed up the exploration process
let's start with mutator based
programming paradigm
a model space is composed of a base
model
and a sequence of mutators here is a
four node sequential model
let's say we want to replace the third
node
max pooling with an inception cell
to explore possible neural architectures
for an image classification task
this inception cell could have two to
five passes
and an operator on each path can be
chosen from
convolution depth wise convolution or
max pool
for this model space we write inception
mutator
the mutator takes the options for
building the model space
for example the number of passes ranges
from
2 to 5 and the list of candidate
operators in the mutate function
it takes a chain of three nodes and
replaces the middle one
with a newly constructed inception cell
specifically it uses an api called truth
to get the decisions from exploration
strategy
that decides how many passes to build in
the sale
and which operations is used on each
pass
also using the truth api
and finally with the defined mutator we
can apply this mutator
to the four node graph to express the
concrete model space
as the user program programmed a model
space
during exploratory training on this
space there are many decisions to make
for example which models should be
prioritized
in search how much time budget to give
each generated model in training do we
need to use early stop
should should weights be shared among
models
these decisions could be made by
exploration strategies
or human currently there have been a lot
of good exploration strategies
such as reinforcement learning grid
search
evolution and annealing outcomes bsn
based optimizations
and a gradient-based search approach
more importantly these exploration
strategies
are reusable by various user-defined
model spaces
this is the architecture of re-sharing
cheat engine takes user-defined model
space
including base model and mutators
then instantiate models following the
model space
while instantiating a model mutators
will be applied one by one to generate a
new model
the mutator will interact with
exploration engine
to get the decisions on which concrete
model to
instantiate next the execution engine
interacts with the exploration strategy
to get the mutation decisions users can
also customize
new exploration strategies following the
interface
exposed by execution exploration engine
human can also interact with the
exploration training process
through this interface
other generated raw data flow graphs
are optimized using cross model
optimizations before training
their training results are collected as
a feedback
these results are fed to the exploration
strategy
for the strategy to make better
decisions
this table shows 8 out of
27 nas solutions currently supported by
richard
many model spaces can be constructed
with three simple mutators
input mutator operator mutator and
inserting mutator
different model spaces and exploration
strategies
can be freely combined our models from a
model space
are usually similar to each other they
usually use the same training data
under the same data pre-processing logic
because they may be mutated
from the same base model they may share
some common layers
moreover some models may share weights
with each other in order to leverage
other models higher accuracy and
training progress
based on these other observations we
propose
three cross model optimizations
they are common sub expression
elimination mixture parallelism
for weight sharing and operator batching
first the data set preprocessor and the
embedding of multiple models might be
same
executing multiple model on the same
server may lead to significant
contention on cpu
especially for mobile models while all
these models use the same non-trainable
prefix operations
the optimization of common sub
expression elimination
will be will be deduplicated
by merging them so that they are
executed only once on cpu
our micro benchmark uh shows m net
0.5 has a cpu utilization
of 75 percent even when running one
model
running more models in the server will
lead to bottleneck on cpu
using richard's cse the data loading and
the pre-processing will be deduplicated
so that more models do not increase cpu
burden
our micro benchmark experiment shows
richards cse can bring
3.4 times improvement
on the training support for mnas net 0.5
with a better size of 210
richards cse can also optimize the
duplication of
tpu based operations this example shows
four models
that use the same input and the
preprocession on cpu
and avert embedding on gpu bird
is a very large model that occupied the
most gpu memory consumption at a time
of the forward person in the cc
optimized model
we dedicate to one gpu for bird so that
we can spare
multiple memories on other gpus to pack
more models
also the pipeline can be further
improved
by overlapping the forward of multiple
models
with birth forward of the next iteration
this is the corresponding experiment our
micro benchmark of texture nas on sst
data set
with four v100 gpus shows nearly two
times
improvement on the total support
in the first end-to-end experiment we
evaluate
how richard can accelerate for
neuroactive search
we choose three famous nas solutions to
evaluate
mnas net nas net and a mobile net
we choose these three because they cover
different combinations
of search spaces and exploration
strategies
both mnasnet and the nasnet use
reinforcement learning
to explore the model space nas net and a
mobile net use the same model space
proposed by nasnet because of the large
model space of the three nut solutions
the exploration process could be very
time consuming
for comparison we compare richard with
two baselines
the exclusive execution strategy trains
one model per gpu at a time this is the
most widely used
strategy in last papers the pack and
baseline changes multiple models per gpu
we also tried to enable nvidia cuda mps
in this packing strategy to train
multiple models per gpu at the same time
we compare the completion time of
exploring
1000 models on four v100 gpus
each model is trained for one epoch on
imagenet dataset
richard achieves up to 2.57 times
speed up on the search time money due to
the optimization
of packing multiple models per gpu under
the common sub expression illumination
when the base size is 32 viciary can
simultaneously
run up to 22 mnas net models on four
gpus
because its explored models are smaller
than that in the other two nas solutions
this result shows an insight that
small models can benefit more from
richard's current
cross model optimizations in the
baselines
we notice simply packing more models
in one gpu without cross model
optimization
could even perform worse than the
exclusive execution
because of heavy resource contention
the second end-to-end experiment is to
speed up
weight shared training which is a very
common technique
adopted in neuroactive search it is also
called one shot nas
instead of training each instantiated
model from the model space independently
weight share training proposes to
inherit
weights of unchanged layers from
previous models to avoid
every model from scratch for example
here we have a
model with four layers where only the
second layer is mutable
there are three candidates relu identity
and leaky relu together defines the
model space
in the first trial relu is chosen to
instantiate
the model the model is trained for a few
mini batches
so that the weights of the convolution
and the dense layer are updated
then the second trial is instantiated by
choosing
identity at the second layer but the
other
three layers remain the same we share
the training
will reuse the weights from the first
trial to continue the training
after a few iterations the third trial
is instantiated
by chosen liquid relu similarly the
weights
are shared from the second trial before
the training
in this way the chaining of unchanged
layers
will not be wasted in new trials which
can greatly reduce
the exploration time sharing weights
using checkpointing could incur
significant
overhead many nas solutions will
manually
build a supernet using dynamic
control flow to encode all possible
choices
in one graph each iteration will
interact
a path of the super graph for training
with this super graph approach there is
no need to checkpoint
and reload the weight for each
instantiated model
which could save the time consumed by
checkpointing and the model
initialization richard could
automatically build
the super graph from defined the model
space
our micro brand mark shows over six
times
speed up using richards super graph
different
from existing nas solutions that
manually build the super graph
richard can automatically build it
directly using the mutator information
however the super graph limits the size
of the model space
because it must fit into the gpu memory
of one gpu
it is hard to scale a super graph
training
to a large gpu cluster because it does
not allow training a lot of trials at
the same time
to speed up with sharing training we
propose
mixed parallelism in richards cross
model optimization
to break the science limitation we use
monopolism
to partition the super graph to multiple
gpus
inside each partition it still activates
one path at a time to mimic the weight
shared training
we feed each partition with a different
batch of data
in a data parallel manner a different
partitions
may share some common operators for
example
node 2 and 3 these nodes will be shared
using parameter servers or collective
communication primitives like all reduce
we evaluate a famous wet shared nas
solution
called spos whichary can reduce the
training time
from 64 hours
to about seven hours
which is an improvement of 8.5 at times
meanwhile luxury can achieve almost the
same
validation accuracy with the sync being
enabled data parallel training
so to conclude this research work
reshari
is the new dm framework designed for
exploratory training
in order to address more and more
requirements on dna model design
richard provides new interface for dm
model developers
to design new models efficiently they
easily
express the model they want to try and
leverage powerful
exploration strategies to speed up the
exploration
their simple but powerful mutator
abstraction
enables high expressiveness reusability
of
exploration strategies and plenty of
rooms
for system optimizations and next my
colleague
scarlett will introduce how richard is
implemented
in ni and how to use richard online
since channel photo sharing this is
scholarly m-a-p-m-e microsoft research
asia in the next 10 to 15 minutes
i will introduce the usage of luxury on
ios 2 demos
and after that we will have open for the
q a
a quick background about richard and i
rishary is actually an innovation
generated from the evolving of an open
source project
called an i which aims to build a
lightweight but very powerful
toolkit to help users to automate
machine learning lifecycle
which usually includes feature
engineering architect search
hyper-prime tuning and model compression
for searching the best
neural architecture and hyper parameters
it provides tons of stator files tuning
algorithms
as well as a set of powerful api for
users
to self-define their own tuning
algorithms this tuning algorithms
generates
promising trail jobs which are
automatically dispatched
by ni to rails training environments
including local machine remote machines
and
cloud options like open pi kobi flow
azure machine learning what's notes
worthy is
it also supports cross-platform hardware
trainings
which can help users to make their the
best use of their
diverse resources the tool is also well
known for its user friendly command line
too
and the under delightful web ui which
enable the users to manage their
machine learning experiences and
runnings and results productively
started from 2018
has kept working on adding more and more
popular automl algorithms
connects to various training services
and platforms
so far we've had already built in 35
popular
automl algorithms in total with nni
the algorithms covers various aspects of
the automl
lifecycle including 12 tuners for
hyper-prime
tuning seven neural active search
algorithms
rhythms five model compression pronouns
are quantizers
two feature selectors and two early stop
algorithms
aside from the communications with
academic and community users we found
the necessarity
of merging and replacing the neural
octet search and the hyper prime tuning
implementation into one more
but once the exploration training method
that's the motivation for the invention
of
lichary in 2.0 release
we first introduced the alpha
implementation of richard
which provides basic apis for
exploration
training since then with two more
continuous releases
we are now on track with the upcoming
formal version
that supports neural active search with
shari in
eye as a quick recap about resharing
method
richard has decoupled model space
from model exploration strategy which
largely improves the efficiency and
clarity of
training explorations among known and
unknown new
models reflecting the design of this
abstraction to the specific
implementation of an
eye we defend a simple process with
only three steps to construct an
inspirational training
which includes defining a model based
model
and adding its mutations bundling search
strategies
and exploring the search space setting
these
evolution goes and extracted the top
models
i will introduce each steps in more
details
in the following slices before the demo
so firstly
usually you only need one line change to
switching a normal model to the niraft
modules
with the base model you are able to
extend it to more variations
by applying analyze mutators in this
code
sequence we we have applied two
different
mutators to the base model the first one
is a layer choice mutator in addition to
the initial
count 2d layer design the layer mutation
allows richard to generate
additional model design options from
mult layer settings
and the input mutator allows richard to
skip connections based on the search
strategies
needs in addition to the layer mutator
and
input mutator we just introduced ni has
another basic mutator called value
mutator
as an example above value value
choice api helps you to choose one value
from
all those candidates it can be in inch
flute
and other series series of parameters
beyond the basic type of mutators and i
also supports
advanced mutators which has more
powerful ability to manipulate the
neural
graph insert mutator allows you to
insert a node directly to the graph
cell mutators provides more flexibility
for the user to define a high level
cell as a building block and use it in
the graph directly
to design more complex mutators that fit
your own
neural active search idea you can
directly
inherit an isometer class to implement
graph mutation logic and then use
mutator subclass
to implement neural architects search
strategy
this is a very high level briefing about
graph mutator
you can always learn more about how to
use
graph mutation apis by visiting the open
source projects
documentation okay next step
is to explore the search space as listed
here
and i had already implement implemented
and provided a set of popular
search strategies for example a random
search strategy can help you randomly
pick up the
models from the search space research
strategy helps to
immunize all the possible models
defined in the space and uh evolution
strategy
is a generic algorithm that can explore
the space based on inheritance and
mutation
as an extensible framework an eye
provided the ability to users
who would like to customize their own
strategy as well
in exam in this demo we will use
directly user in an out-of-box
basin optimization strategy tpe strategy
as an example okay evolution is always
task oriented and closely connected to
the context
it usually require customization work
for business logics
in an eye we release the two evaluators
majorly as example sample codes for
reference
user need to if user can refer to the
sample
codes and customize their own strategy
and evaluators directly
in the demo we use the sample
classification directly
here okay in in our background
introduction
uh let's take a closer look at the first
i shall demo for new rocket search
ritueri is a deep learning framework
that supports the exploratory training
on a neural network model space
developed by the microsoft nni team
this example will show ritueri's ability
to express and explore the model space
for neural architecture search and hyper
parameter tuning in a simple way
let's start the journey with ritueri
step 1 express the model space
model space is defined by users to
express a set of models that they want
to explore
which contains potentially good
performing models
in rituary framework a model space is
defined with two parts
a base model and possible mutations on
the base model
step 1.1 define the base model
defining a base model is almost the same
as defining a pie torch model
usually you only need to replace the
code that imports pi torch to use nni
wrapped pi
torch modules this is a very simple
example of defining a base model
step 1.2 define the model mutations
a base model is only one concrete model
not a model space
nni provides apis and primitives for
users to express how the base model can
be mutated
i.e a model space that includes many
models
the following will use inline mutation
api's layer choice to choose a layer
from candidate operations
and use input choice to try out skip
connection
step 2 explore the model space we will
demo the multi-trial nas method first
in the multi-trial nas process the
search strategy repeatedly generates new
models
and the model evaluator is for training
and validating each generated model
the obtained performance of a generated
model is collected and sent to the
search strategy for generating better
models
users can choose a proper search
strategy to explore the model space
and use a chosen or user defined model
evaluator to evaluate the performance of
each sampled model
step 2.1 choose or write a search
strategy
currently ritueri supports many common
strategies
such as random regularized evolution and
tpe
etcetera according to the apis of
radiary
you can also customize a new strategy
easily and there we use the tpe strategy
as an example
step 2.2 choose or write a model
evaluator
the model evaluator should correctly
identify the use case of the model and
the optimization goal
for example on a classification task and
data set as needed
the loss function could be cross entropy
and the optimized metric could be the
accuracy
rishieri provides two ways for users to
write a new model evaluator
in the context of pi torch ritueri has
provided two built-in model evaluators
designed for simple use cases
classification and regression
these two evaluators are built upon the
awesome library pi
torch lightning here we take a
classification task on cipher 10 data
set as an example
step 2.3 configure the experiment
after all the above are prepared it is
time to configure an experiment to do
the model search
the basic experiment configuration is as
follows
nni allows users to run experiments in
different training platforms to speed up
the search
like local machine remote servers open
pi
cube flow framework controller on k8s
dl workspace azure machine learning
adapt dl other cloud options and even
hybrid mode
there we use the local mode with gpu
speeding up
step 2.4 run and view the experiment
you can launch the experiment now it is
worth mentioning that nni provides a
powerful web ui to help users view the
experiment results and make more
advanced analyses
open the web ui url in your browser you
can view detailed information about the
experiment
including the best metric and the top
trials
click into the experiment detail page
you can see all the submitted trial jobs
in the point graph of them
in addition there are more advanced
features waiting for you to discover on
nni's web ui
step 2.5 export the top model
nni also provides an api to export the
top k model scripts searched by rituary
so you can use them easily
thanks for watching and looking forward
to your feedback
okay compared to independently training
each model from scratch
which we call multi-trial nas
is that is what we just demoed one shot
algorithms
greatly reduces the computational
resources this type of
algorithms leverage with sharing among
models
in a neurological search space to train
a super knight
and use this supernat to get the
selection of better models
as introduced by triangle rishari has
done lots of work on the sharing of
optimizations and applied this
optimizations to one short
on the inline implementation we have
also provided the supports to a set of
well-known one-shot algorithms out of
books and and
as always we have also provided a lot of
aps for you to customize your own one
shot on top of an
eye so as the definite
definition of model space part is the
same as
multi trial demo the second demo will
directly started from the
the second step explore the model space
with a defined model space users can
explore the space in two ways
one is the multi-trial nas method which
searches by evaluating each sampled
model independently
the other is using one shot weight
sharing based search
which consumes much less computational
resource compared to the first one
in this part we focus on this one-shot
approach
the principle of the one-shot approach
is combining all the models in a model
space into one big model
usually called supermodel or super graph
it takes charge of both search training
and testing
by training and evaluating this big
model
ritueri has supported some classic
one-shot trainers
like darts trainer enis trainer proxilis
nas trainer
single path trainer and users can
customize a new one-shot trainer
according to the apis provided by
ritueri conveniently
here we show an example to use dart's
trainer manually
similarly the optimal structure found
can be exported
thanks for watching and looking forward
to your feedback
as a summary for the key takeaways
thanks for watching the demos and
as a key takeaways for the for the
entire session
for nas researchers and developers
richard has provided just enough
abstractions for the researchers to
concentrate
on the certain research problem and for
the model developers
richard provides the new interface for
dn and model developers to design new
models
efficiently we have we also implemented
research on ni which is a tool having
lots of support
on connecting to the training services
and
supporting a very delightful web ui so
which with research
implementation online both researchers
and developers can want new dna models
with extensible api and user-friendly
use
user experiences so
last before the q a session we'd like to
take a minute
to thanks for the call researchers and
developers who had contributed to ni in
the past
currently and in the future and thanks
for our leadership
teams who have given us the kindly
support
on exploring the new things in this
domain and thanks to
our our contributors in the community
though we never met
face to face we are we had already
working on a great tool together to
making
automated deep learning model develop
better
so that's all for today thanks for
listening and we are open for questions
hey everyone thanks for attending the
introduction of richard
in a deep learning exploration training
platform online
webinar and lab q a i'm scarlett lee
in msri and together with me is the my
colleague
chuan lujang over the next 15 minutes
we are going to be to be answering top
questions submitted by the audience
let's get started so our first
question is is it possible to utilize
richard to
minimal minimally replicate popular nas
product like like mobile knight v3 three
etcetera
uh channel would you like to answer the
question i thought
you already have a short answer in the
chat log do you want to
explain more to the audience
uh sure this is a good question uh
so the answer is it's possible a russia
is designed for this purpose
uh uh it's for uh minimize the design
and implement of new uh nasa
exams and for developing
new models more efficiently we have
implemented
several nas auxins including nas net
spos mobile mobile net um
mobile net and other auxins
so it should be easy to implement the
nas space
for producing mobile net v3
and reproduce the search process
of mobile network v3 and
the implementation effort should be
small with the referee
thank you i see there are people already
open up
yeah go ahead so are you
want to continue the answer
uh if you haven't asked me the new
question right
yeah there is a new question actually
people are yeah
go ahead yeah that's a new
question the question is can
uh
yeah can i use richard to change again
actually we um we have uh
this kind of example uh in our uh
pr uh uh online and uh
the answer is yes we can we can uh use
luxury to train again and
uh to uh specify
many candidate uh possible hyper
parameter values
and architectures to automatically find
their best game model
nice i thought there are questions about
whether
richard is an open source project and
weather and yes it is and it is not only
resharing it is uh
richard is part of ni project which is
already
been there for two or two and more years
two years and
it only not only has nas algorithms and
not support but also has
model compression support and hyper
primary tuning supports
and etc and i saw there are already
people asking
already recent issues after listening to
this webinar thank you for
thank you guys for actively um
connect us in the github and uh
let's move on to the next question
which is is it possible to specify
hardware or wire constraints
in the search space as as is commonly
explored
in works like mobile mobile.
that etc channel would you like to
answer that
question yeah so this is a good question
hardware aware is uh is a very important
scenario
and usually we uh we design or search
a dna model is for
for a specific hardware or device so
for richard hardware constraints can be
put
in exploration strategy as the
condition as this kind of condition or
constraints
is used for sampling new models or
several models from the model space
and we we have another work
which does latency prediction because
uh many hardware aware
awareness they they usually use
for example flops as their indicator to
show whether the model
is qualified enough so we actually have
another work
to directly predict their uh uh
their influence latency and
memory consumption of each sampled
model and this this work will be
all is being integrated with shari and
ni
thanks general there is another question
about
yeah thank you for that answer and there
is a
another question coming do you have any
conclusions about
optimal ordering of choices in weight
sharing
um yeah actually we did
several research works on this topic
and we are trying to understand how
web sharing works and our conclusion is
that
for the normal web sharing that is
users specify different types of
operators
for one layer then
then the network could also randomly
sample each
operator to build
to build a sub model and this
type of approach can find a reasonably
good
uh good model from the third space
but it's pretty hard to find the best
model
or the optimal ordering
for this search space and according to
my understanding i
um i think maybe
the super kernel approach could have
more potential
on finding good models the super
kernel means that the candidate
operators for uh one layer
are very similar to each other for
example they are all uh convolutional
operator
then we can combine these con
convolutional operators into one super
convolutional operator
uh to share uh weights among each other
maybe this way i have higher potential
to solve this problem
there is a question upcoming question
related to hardware it is
asking is it is it possible to use
richard on mac
with m1 chip um plus
np mpu ps mpu
so uh in general we already support mike
mike os and windows and linux
but uh specifically we did not try that
that that cheap out so probably
if you have that that however please try
it and let us know
okay so next upcoming question is
is richard evaluating the experiment by
loose function or accuracy score
yeah for this question yeah
so actually how to evaluate a
user-defined model uh is um
is decided by by user and uh
uh so user with we share a user
specifies
uh their model space uh using our apis
and then they to write
an evaluator uh for example uh
they can write this kind of evaluator
with
python lighting to specify how to train
each sample model from the model space
and the exploration strategy
in richard will receive the uh
the evaluated the evaluation results
for example accuracy or loss and use
this
metric to to
sample the next the next
next candidate candidate model
thank you so there is another question
how to obtain model graph
from a path or tensorflow model
so what we do support that for pad touch
we use
touchscript to extract model graph from
the petage model
and for tensorflow we use similar way to
obtain the model graph relying on the
tensorflow provided utilities for the
current implementation of
sharing on we mainly focus on the petal
framework right now
okay so let's see other questions
should i open open issues for this kind
of suggestion
on case studies yes please do so
we we do very actively actively
interact with our users on the github
through issues and discussions
github recently opened a discussion
section which can helping users to
discuss about new ideas
and designs you are also encouraged to
go
through go to the discussion session to
discuss with us
if you have good ideas or case studies
right how to train a campaign model when
this model contains
multiple models is there any
limitations with the approaches channel
would you like to
explain about this scenario and support
sure um this is a good question and this
question is mainly about
the optimizations that we designed in
the shari
and actually we are also uh implementing
this kind of of
optimizations online it is called
cto execution engine
and uh for this question uh how to
uh train multiple models uh
together and uh it's uh uh it's pretty
simple
uh because uh uh we we
uh simply sum the loss uh
of um of multiple models together to
become
a uh a new one a one new
loss and uh and then we optimize
this loss uh with uh uh with user
specifier optimizer
and uh in this approach um
these multiple models are trained
together
this approach has some limitations
first these models should i should have
should have the same batch size so that
we can
we can feed the feed training data
once without to deal with
different exercises and
the second and the second constraint is
that
they should usually they should have
their uh
have their same training epochs and the
same optimizers
these conditions are uh are not hard
constrained
because if two models have
different epochs for example
two epochs and three box respectively
we can combine these two models to chain
two epochs
and then change the left one for another
one epoch
yeah and maybe there are there are other
uh other limitations um but
for our implementation online we only
targeted the simplest
scenario in order to make these
optimizations robust and stable
nice um so there is another question
uh could optimizations like
deduplication and fusion
applied across multiple automate automl
jobs
can you answer help answer this question
um yeah actually uh by design we only
apply across model optimizations
on the models within one uh uh
a one richard experiment uh
because with our mutator abstraction we
can easily
figure out which part is the same and
which parts are different
among the samples of the sample models
so it's not that easy to
apply or apply cross-mode organizations
across on the models across
different resurrection experiments or
on some ad hoc submitted
dna models but as long as there are
some approach to identify the uh the
same part
of those models then our cross model
optimization techniques
are general enough to be applied on them
thank you so there is a new question
uh if the resurrect can automatic
automatically test how the cnn ship
uh adaptable database best
uh like like convolution channel number
uh
yeah yeah you got the answer you got a
question
yeah uh i think the question is
can we shari automatically
figure out the best deal model shape
for example convolution channel number
fully connected fully connected
sites to adapt
each given data set
i think this question is money about
is about that user provider or data set
then how to provide um
the best deal model for this data set uh
and i think uh firstly
uh for the design of richard expect that
users uh to specify the model space
and uh actually there have been many
uh commonly used uh search spaces
to automatically generate a dml model
for each given data set and
we can implement this kind of thing
space
with the richard api then
we can provide this this functionality
that
we can automatically find the best model
from this
specified space space for this data set
so uh so the the short short answer is
that uh
to adapt uh layers
uh layers input output shape
for a specific data set users have to
specify
candidate options for
further choices of each layer's shape
and then automatically search models for
the data set
thanks chalu i i think it's almost
at the end of the the webinar so we can
we can
wait for another question if there is a
question
coming in um in the coming
10 hours 30 30 minutes 30 seconds
if not um
we probably it's time to thank you for
thank you firstly thank you all for
attending today we appreciate
your participation and interest in this
topic
if you are interested in learning more
we already
listed some great resources in the
results list to the right
of your screen the list includes our
the the link to our github url and also
the
presentation we are using today and also
the paper
richard has published and uh
and some of the videos we are using so
we are
looking forward to seeing how you can
build your research
on and evolving that in the in the
neural access search area and other
automl
areas using using an eye and root sherry
and other tools that we can
work together so have a good
great day thank you thank you all
thank you